i'm wes chatham and here are five shows
to check out if you
love the expanse on binge guide thanks
wes
i couldn't have said it better myself
and we are big fans of the expanse on
amazon prime
with three certified fresh seasons
filled with galactic action
existential drama and world exploring
adventure it's not hard to see why
so if you're a fan looking for more to
love after the expanse
we think that these space fairy shows
will launch your next few [ __ ] sessions
into a new dimension starting with our
family-friendly pick
lost in space this netflix reboot of the
tv series of the same name follows
adventures of the robinson family as
they navigate the cosmos after getting
lost in space i mean the title says it
all what can i say
look beyond the title though and you'll
find a modern take on the classic series
with something for everyone in your own
family with tons of safe for kids action
it's coupled with a large heart and
ambitious production values that should
attract sci-fi adventure fans
and with a third and final season on the
way you can quickly get caught up with
the first two seasons in just about 20
hours which sounds blissful compared to
being
you know lost in space okay i'm done
sorry
next up is our throwback pick and that
is going to battlestar galactica
this reimagining of the 70s tv show
follows humanity's war with the android
race known as the cylons and bucks the
trend of the original spin on star wars
in favor of a darker tone and seriously
heady twist that strongly resonated with
modern audiences
with two certified fresh seasons and a
massive cult following the four season
series has been praised for its
addictive high-minded themes and complex
storylines
and has frequently been called one of
the greatest sci-fi series
of all time with 76 episodes total you
can binge this series in about 56 hours
which is nothing compared to the amount
of time you'll spend contemplating all
the storylines
another entry into a classic universe is
our certified fresh pick star trek
discovery
the cbs all access series takes place
roughly a decade before star trek the
original series and explores the earlier
days of the united federation of planets
and the advent of war with the klingons
critics praised discovery's ability to
forge its own path while effectively
dramatizing new takes on the lore that
results in a
solid franchise installment for the next
generation of trek fans
with three seasons you can watch star
trek discovery in about 26 hours after
which you'll have boldly gone where no
couch has gone before
next up is our audience pick going to
the alternative history series for all
mankind
this apple tv plus drama from battlestar
galactica creator ronald d moore blends
true life characters with fictional
events like the russians landing on the
moon first to ask the question
what would have happened if the space
race never ended with stellar production
values incredible cast and some very
timely storylines the show has
the right stuff to be unpredictable and
awe-inspiring
you can watch the entire first season in
about 10 hours and good news
season 2 is a go for launch in early
2021 so be sure to keep a lookout
and rounding out our list is our
editor's pick raised by wolves
this ridley scott produced hbo max
series revisits many of the sci-fi
masters
hallmark themes including androids space
colonization and
lots of action all while asking pretty
big questions about human nature and
what it means to be alive
critics say the show is filled with
ridley scott trademarks like imagination
and otherworldly imagery that will
stimulate the mind and eye but also adds
a surprising amount of heart
and with just 10 episodes you can binge
all of raised by wolves in about 10
hours which i hear is how long it feels
to hibernate for deep space exploration
right friends hopefully this list will
open your eyes to a whole new galaxy of
content to explore
be sure to check out the new rotten
tomatoes is wrong podcast from rotten
tomatoes because fresh rotten is just
the beginning of the conversation and
new episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't want to
miss out on any future recommendations
based around the movies and shows that
you love be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell
thanks so much for watching our video
and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you